pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour les départs de pâques on avait
réservé aux parisiens une agréable
surprise a mise en service du premier
tronçon de l'autoroute sud qui a
inauguré monsieur robert buron ministre
des travaux publics capables de débiter
5000 voitures à l'heure voici donc
ouverte la grande voix du midi et de la
côte d'azur
avec son embranchement sur l'aéroport
d'orly ce premier tronçon a nécessité la
destruction de 150 logements et
l'édification de 59 ouvrages d'art
rançon de la vie moderne grande
dévoreuse de kilomètres
[Musique]
on sait que la vie moderne est aussi une
grande dévoreuse de papier imprimé par
les emprises de la gare de lyon la sncf
et les nouvelles messageries de la
presse parisienne viennent de créer une
gare spécialisé dans la diffusion et
l'expédition des journaux et périodiques
la gare du papier imprimé
impressionnante univers que ce vol de
tri avec ses séries de casiers et setra
de wagonnets ici chaque jour 400 à 600
tonnes de publications arrive des
imprimeries qui sont méthodiquement
trier empaquetés et expédié par trains
spéciaux pour quelle heure précise
chacune d'elles soit à sa place dans les
éventaires de besançon de palavas les
flots ou de biarritz la gare du
charolais en effet dessert toutes les
villes de france petites ou grandes qui
sont situés au sud d'une ligne qui ré
donnant à mulhouse
[Musique]
la garde du papier imprimé une image
impressionnante de la vie moderne
[Musique]
stop de tananarive occupé par quatorze
mille spectateurs
le président de la république malgache
monsieur sirhan et monsieur maurice
herthum haut commissaire à la jeunesse
et aux sports au président et à
l'ouverture des premiers jeux de la
communauté cérémonie qui coïncidait avec
la signature des accords reconnaissant
l'indépendance de madagascar
[Musique]
les jeux réunissait dix neuf équipes
représentant 800 athlètes venus de tous
les pays de la communauté réunion
extrêmement symbolique par conséquent de
monsieur hertzog a pu dire qu'elle était
l'expression d'une volonté librement
affirmé de rapprochement et de
confrontation
[Musique]
et la cérémonie d'ouverture prenait fin
avec le traditionnel serment olympique
prononcée par le champion malgache crabe
et mila au nom de ses 800 camarades
[Musique]
avenue victor hugo à paris
derrière cette façade un père et une
mère ont vécu cinquante six heures d'une
affreuse angoisse on avait vu entrer
haletant le chauffeur et lanners tout
près d'eux le petit eric peugeot avait
été enlevé il devait par la suite au
jardin d'enfants du golf de saint cloud
reconstitué avec les policiers les
étapes du rap
[Musique]
depuis les visages des passants
interrogeait les volets fermés
enfin après trois jours d'angoissé
l'heureuse nouvelle éclatait le petit
eric avait retrouvé son père sa mère et
son frère aîné on peut croire impossible
le retour d'un tel crime
l'un des plus horribles qu'on puisse
imaginer
[Musique]
avec son million d'habitants quand le
portugal en compte neuf à peine et
l'importance de son port lisbonne tient
une place prépondérante son rôle
économique au point de transit entre le
monde et l'intérieur du pays
la désigne d'ailleurs comme le centre
pilote d'un essor industriel qui ces
dernières années a touché le portugal
c'est dans ses faubourgs des deux côtés
de l'estuaire du tage que ce groupe ait
déjà les éléments d'une industrie encore
dans l'enfance
mais aujourd'hui la première raffinerie
de pétrole est né et un énorme complexe
sidérurgique est en construction
l'heure est venue où le portugal va
tenter avec les ressources de son sous
sol
l'aventuré industrielle des nations
modernes
[Musique]
jusqu'ici c'est surtout de l'agriculture
que le pays tire et ses ressources
exportateurs de vins et il n'y a pas que
le porto qui s'exporte exportateurs de
liège
il en est le plus gros fournisseur du
monde exportateurs de résine qui
l'envoie sur tous les océans
[Musique]
il est également exportateurs de bois et
exportateurs d'huile que produisent
depuis les temps les plus anciens les
forêts d'olivier qui abrite moutons et
chèvres dans la plus vieille chilienne
des traditions
pays d'agriculture et dans quelle
l'agriculture exige l'effort humain son
sol pierreux se trouve un peu propice à
l'abondance des machines pour cette
cause on laboure peu autre acteur et
chaque printemps les journalière en
longues rangées vont désherber les
chances de play pays où l'effort est
nécessaire peuple solide qui ne ménage
pas sa peine avec dans la journée le
seul arrêt d'une collation rustique
qu'on goûte à l'ong boucher silencieuse
peuple de paysans robuste et seube dont
les toits se cachent dans les de
géraniums d'aloès et de lauriers roses
ou les lavoirs sont à toute heure peuplé
de femmes coiffées à l'image des
péruvienne de chapeau de feutre
on lave beaucoup au portugal et où le
dimanche
la distraction des âmes et de lancer le
palais de faire dans une sorte de
mélancolie qui est la marque du peuple
portugais
[Musique]
le long des routes d'innombrables moulin
à vent tendent leurs ailes qui ne tourne
plus l'âge industriel dans lequel le
portugal vient d'entrer leur pose
aujourd'hui des barrages qui tendent au
double but de créer la force électrique
est de permettre une irrigation
favorable
mais pour l'instant ces innovations ne
change pas le paysage on voit toujours
c'est cavalca paysanne qui vont au
marché ses cavalières à panier et ses
cavaliers à bonnet de laine qui forment
l'animation coutumières de la route
portugaise a toujours ses bandes de
chevaux convoyés par les calmes pinos
qui sont les élus locaux des cowboys et
des gardians c'est le lyrisme du
portugal de l'étrier de bois au visage
buriné par les saisons une solennité
paysanne surgit de cette figure dressé
sur l'horizon du ribat est jo ou vague
comme un cas marc des troupeaux de
taureaux destinés aux arènes comme il
surgit de ses paysages qu'on dirait
ordonné par un peintre mystique où toute
la grandeur et celle de l'homme qui
salue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici un mois maintenant que l'afrique
du sud vit dans le drame qui oppose 11
millions de noirs à 3 millions de blancs
11 millions de noirs qui se sont élevés
contre l'obligation qui leur était faite
d'être porteur d'un laissez-passer
permanent il ne s'agit là d'ailleurs que
d'une des plus récentes dispositions des
lois de ségrégation raciale
car ici blancs et noirs vivent une vie
parfaitement séparer établissements pour
blanc interdit aux hommes de couleur
chaque race à ces moyens de transport
auto bus ou tramway
[Musique]
dans les gares chacun a son escalier
voir son gant partout entre les races
cette barrière est nette
c'est contre ces discriminations
qu'aujourd'hui la population noire s'est
dressé un peu partout et c'est ainsi
qu'au poste de police de nyanga elle a
commencé par incendier le fichier des
fameux laisser passer
[Musique]
cependant le docteur werver premier
ministre est partisan de la politique de
ségrégation été victime d'un attentat
[Musique]
mais contre toute attente c'était un
blanc qui avait tiré
[Musique]
la crise en est ainsi arrivé à son
paroxysme et dans tout le pays
rennes une attente angoissée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]